ladies and gentlemen
the um
motion for this debate as you now know
is
too many people go to university
if you look at this
bunch of people in front of you
they have all gone to university
or are going to go to university
except me
i thought i would just mention this that
people born in 1924
tended not to go to university because
there was
an attractive alternative
you got called up
um
my university connection
is actually more impressive than most
other people here
in that i've been a director of a
university on three occasions
and on the first occasion i was not in
the electorate rectangle
but i was mobbed by the staff
when they found out
that i could wear a peter's nose gown
and they didn't have to make a new
garden for the new rectangle
uh
the way we are playing this tonight
is that um
the fours were sitting on my left will
begin
are they not sitting on right now
they're sitting on my right
the four sitting on my right will begin
and they will speak for eight or nine
minutes but no more
and when they have done their piece it
is up to you to ask questions
let us commence with um
claire fox
who will speak for the mission
okay will you
make your way there
sorry
[Music]
[Applause]
evening everybody
i am one of those egalitarians who since
going to university from my bog standard
comprehensive was determined to storm
the ivory towers and allow ever greater
numbers to enter the hallowed halls of
academia
i haven't changed my mind and yet i'm
going to argue that too many people are
going to university
why not because i have a rose-tinted
sentimentality about the good old days
because what more and more people are
being given access to today
promiscuously labeled as higher
education is a pale imitation of what
university was
or is ideally and the degrees being
awarded too often and merely credentials
not worth the paper they're written on
context is all
what has been the basis of this massive
expansion of higher education how did so
many young people become equipped to
deal with knowledge at a higher level
was it the school leavers magically
became brighter or the educational
standards are rising and schools getting
better
well i don't believe in magic and the
evidence from the schools is fairly
dubious
the latest ofsted annual report says
that more than half of all secondary
schools are failing to provide children
with a good education
and parents are so desperate to get a
place in the few good local state
schools that do exist that they lie
about where they live
and a location near a top performing
secondary school can add up to three
hundred thousand pounds to the value of
your property in london
well maybe i'm being cynical what about
the evidence of the league tables and
the increased gcse and a-level passes
well i don't believe it it's been
recently revealed that nine out of the
ten most improved schools achieved their
higher ranking because their head
teachers entered pupils for the easier
emasculated vocational qualifications so
that the health and social care
qualification was given the equivalent
of four gcse passes it's called cheating
let's be honest you don't need an a
level to work out that a levels a what
they used to be
1965 to 1980 there was a steady pass
rate of 68
the following 25 years it zoomed up to
96 percent the question is not is there
great inflation rather the question is
how can this not be grade inflation
when i hear that half of scotland's
universities are forced to offer
remedial classes to new students you
realize that the opening up of
universities doesn't necessarily mean
better educated school leavers
but maybe i'm being cheap to quibble
about schools maybe the expansion of
universities is happening in
circumstances of unprecedented
commitment to intellectual pursuits
scholarship and academic rigour maybe we
live in a society where there's a
renaissance in the cultivation of the
mind and a new respect for knowledge
oh but what that what's that i hear a
recent education minister charles clark
telling us that knowledge for his own
sake is a bit dodgy
what's actually unprecedented is the
official philistinism of education
policy
rather than a celebration of education
as a valuable end education is sold
merely as a means to a variety of
non-educational ends we have a narrow
functional attitude to knowledge now
incorporated into the purposes of
universities today
if you look at any new report on
universities the leech report the new
hefty report the role of universities is
we are told to make the economy more
efficient to make students more
employable
universities are told to close
forge closer links with employers
they're told to act as skills brokerages
and i can't even say that word it's so
jargon written and they're told that
they must meet the skills priorities of
the local workplaces and students are
told they should go to universities as a
requirement for getting a job so the
glittering prizes being offered today
are merely credentials for work and it's
no surprise of the popularity of
vocational courses such as media studies
academic standards are only valued as a
proof that that they are proof of worth
in the job market and for employability
in 2000 the then education minister
baroness blackstone said that all
courses should make their standards
explicit and this is a quote as a key
part of ensuring that graduates are
prepared for the world of work which
meant that professors of literature i
know were forced to work closely through
their curriculum to prove that they
contain employability and at one point
somebody told me that a close reading of
poetry was actually good evidence that
reading company accounts could be
achieved in the future
now seeing university as a root to a job
is very different from the atmosphere of
the past after my a levels was great
excitement in my home it meant i could
get a good job in the bank
i was disdainful and in fact i rebelled
i didn't want a job i dreamed of ibsen
and shakespeare i went to university in
defiance
today there's no room for such
irrelevant and arcane pursuits of
knowledge today's dreams are more
limited
today i'd be told to go to university as
a way to get the job in the bank
when the university of strathclyde and
paisley announced that it was issuing
laptops to undergraduates the dean of
faculty explained the aim
quote to equip those with
cross-disciplinary skills that make them
extremely appealing to employers
less dreams more utilitarian nightmare
this credentialism i think helps breed
an anti-scholarship
ethos in universities and even justifies
laziness
frequently students want to know how the
recommended readings or the lectures or
the essays or the books contribute to
their final degree
it's hardly their fault because they're
read on an education system that sees
education only as a means to an end so
they only embrace what they need to get
them through their degree anything
beyond is seen a waste of as a waste of
time
maybe i'm being unfair because there's
more to the government's enthusiasm for
mass higher education and utilitarianism
around skills and employability
the education secretary there was and
god knows there's a lot of them as this
speech indicates and but anyway david
blunkett when he was in he claimed quote
widening access to higher education is a
key priority and critical to tackling
social exclusion
but the politically correct language of
social exclusion and inclusion is just
as instrumental as the skills language
this is social engineering and it's not
about giving working-class kids eaten
like school education so that they can
get a university education in fact it's
very it's actually opposed to such a
meritocratic ideal
the role of universities as social
includers treats educational priorities
with contempt and instead its main aim
is correcting social inequality
funding for universities has been
reorganized over recent years to give
those universities who take the socially
excluded from lower social economic
groups
financial incentives and top
universities have threatened that they
will have to take poor students or have
their
millions of pounds in their budgets cut
the proposal of the working party of aim
higher a government body is that c
grades for disadvantage should be
counted as equivalent as a for others
social inclusion is also used to justify
emasculating assessment and curriculum
standard essays and exams and
traditional academic subjects are
considered to be too exclusive and
elitist for the masses
in the past ambitious working-class
students might have been rare but at
least they were judged on their own
merits and their own abilities as
intellectual equals and now
working-class students are patronized as
though they need differential treatment
as though they can't handle the demands
of academia unless they're watered down
on their behalf
now going to universities is either an
extension of school on route to a job or
to enhance people's social standing but
it's treated almost as a routine and
that's the thing that's most dangerous
there is an expectation and often viewed
indifferently by the young that they
will go to university whatever they're
bound to
in the past students had to compete for
university and in such an environment
students had to stretch themselves
intellectually and prove their worth
now it's universities who have to prove
themselves and compete to recruit school
leavers faculty meetings are more like
marketing meetings people sit around and
discuss how to make courses more
attractive appealing sexy they discuss
advertising and brand loyalty
one of the consequences of this is that
academics treat universities like
they're being selling wares and students
are turning to consumer and buyers and
with the exception of a relatively small
number of privileged universities it's a
buyer's market
it's turned education on its head
students are no longer the would-be
apprentices who have to demonstrate that
they deserve to be accepted by the most
advanced minds and researchers in the
field is rather students who are the
masters who now must be flattered and
conjoled cajoled by humble lecturers and
now that students are paying fees this
consumer model is institutionalized
baroness deech the independent
adjudicator for higher education who
deals with student complaints explains
that fee paying students now view going
to university as a service provision and
quote she says it's like joining a gym
you pay me you pay
merely sorry you pay and they provide
the facilities and the trainers
from the point of view of service
provision the customer is always right
but how disastrous in an academic ethos
but it might well explain why there's
degree uh grade inflation
lecturers who are friends of mines are
exhausted to mark positively told that
if there's not enough two ones or first
in their department it's the problem
with their teaching rarely with the
students because the customer is always
right and or else it explains i think as
well a growing complaint called you in
higher education and the fact that
students are increasingly litigious and
use appeals uh to challenge marks which
they don't think they deserved they want
better as though they just bought a
dodgy tv
again it's not students fault
institutions now use routinely student
satisfaction surveys and student
feedback forms to ask students to judge
the merits of courses and lecturers the
least educated people in the university
and now judging the quality of that
university and any lecturer with a
reputation for running difficult courses
or being hard a hard marker or not
supplying ready-made pre-prepared
lecture notes is unlikely to thrive in
this consumer human consumerist
orientated campus environment
certainly the evidence is that students
are shying away from hard subjects
70 university science departments have
closed or been restructured over the
last seven years
if
if academics are student service
providers then of course it's not their
job to question or criticize the tastes
values or opinions of potential
customers but actually academics should
be in the business of educating their
students taste of encouraging to
question their values and challenging
their opinions
indeed one of the most distinct and
significant dimensions of academic
pedagogy in an act intellectual activity
is precisely that this customer is not
always right
in this new world where what matters is
competing for students is that my one
minute sir just a minute i've got a
minute thank you no repetition
i couldn't resist in this new world
where what matters is competing for
students and keeping them satisfied any
degrees that attract students can pass
muster regardless of their intellectual
merit i know a new labor type you argue
against my dumbing down these this
boasts that larger numbers are studying
music no the conservators trials aren't
bursting to the seams with state pupils
studying classical music he means
there's been explosion of popular
musical degrees you can now get a degree
in e-music on podcasting youtube and
itunes coventry university apply now
southampton solents university's new
degree in standup comedy might sound
like a joke but actually because it's
attracting lots of students it must be
okay and shockingly even anti-rational
quackery the antithesis of reason is now
acceptable in the ivory towers there are
now 42 degree courses in complementary
medicine i'll make my final point
if you don't go to university it's not a
disaster but it is disastrous if more
and more people go to universities where
they're unable to distinguish quantity
from quality of course it's not
happening everywhere oxbridge is okay
but what's on offer to the majority the
many
the many
is dumb down
third rate rubbish vote for the motion
thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah thank you
to oppose the merchant
uh
we have
onora o'neal
for nine minutes
[Music]
why would anyone think that too many
people go to university that's the task
i set myself why do they think it i
suspect because they hang on to a cozy
obsolescent view of what universities
are are for
go back 50 years
they were mainly for those of us who
really loved reading and studying there
were lots of ways into professions and
top jobs where you didn't need to go
near a university lawyers didn't need
degrees accountants didn't
successful business people certainly
didn't the pupils of illustrious schools
maintained and independent
didn't send all their pupils to
university
if universities were still what they
were 50 years ago
then of course it's quite plausible that
too many people are going there but
these are different institutions and
nobody should be taken in by the
continuity of the word
people go to them for good reasons and
one is to enter professions and
management and get a good job and there
are vast changes in our economy that
make this a very big enterprise
figures are not usually part of debates
but i thought if we're to get real you
need to know just a little bit
the number of he enrollments in the
united kingdom and the figures 404 5 and
056 are now available
2.3 million up to
that's
five six up two percent from oh four
five a million of them are part time
forty five percent are doing science
subjects science is rather generously
interpreted so nursing will come out as
science and some other things
there's an incre huge increase and it's
continuing
so why are people against it well one
thing is some people think that's
competition i don't like competition it
will make it harder to enter professions
walks of life i like
too much competition for top jobs isn't
a happy thought if one aspires to one
but it's just nothing new
when few of us went to university there
were many fewer such jobs it was still
hugely competitive and trying to choke
off the competition by limiting the
places is probably not a particularly
attractive let alone popular move
other thought people have is not that
it's too much competition for me but
that too many of those who go to
university
think are leaving it unqualified for any
job top or other
well i think there's several points to
be made some of them even if they're not
well qualified might be more educated
three years of study never was a serious
meal ticket and most professional jobs
of course require additional
qualification skills and entry was and
it's going to be competitive
now is the good evidence of unemployable
graduates
not very good at present
one would expect a system in which jobs
are not centrally allocated to have bits
of over and under supply and that the
less competent would be shown up and
they'd fail their degrees or fail to get
the sort of employment they really want
one it would expect university courses
to spread out the talent if some people
are going to be really really successful
others will be less so that happens but
unemployable graduates on a mass scale
is not the evidence we have
another thought you might have which
might make you in favor of the motion is
you might think oh well it's all at the
expense of real skills
that's code for something
what people may be worried about may not
be that their own prospects are less
rosy in a mass age or their children's
prospects but that
we aren't getting training enough people
in technical skills not enough plumbers
not enough competence in foreign
languages not enough numeracy true all
of it true
but it isn't because the people who have
refused to gover plumbing are
languishing in the universities it is
because too many leave school wholly
unqualified don't stay after 16
take those famous undemanding options at
secondary school
and are heavily incentivized to avoid
skills
we need to do better the number of
unskilled jobs likely to fall fast in a
global economy but we really wouldn't uh
do ourselves a good turn by reducing the
university intake we need to persuade
people who give up long before
university looms to take themselves and
their futures more seriously
the fe bill now before parliament does
address some of these issues whether
successfully i'm not sure
then there's the thought which is again
a public spirited thought the trouble is
there are sub-standard degrees
and this is probably true
although many who say this
do no more than gesture at a university
or subject that they suspect of sin
it's almost certainly true because the
he sector is huge and although it is
closely inspected and assessed the
inspection is often too formal
and the content that isn't uh taken
seriously enough
and of course we know that the
applicants haven't always been well
taught and we know that the examination
system a levels for example are not
really any longer fit for purpose
so to anyone who says there's a great
deal that is substandard i suggest look
for the evidence try to quantify the
evidence look at the amount of failure
but don't start out from a false premise
that the system is trying to be an
inflated version of what we had 50 years
back
and if anyone says well nevertheless
even if it is something different
failure should be eliminated and
inadequacy is intolerable i would say
get real
consider the amount of the system
size of the system consider whether it
would be possible to run such a system
into entirely adequate standards
another thought people have is well
given what's happened to the system the
degree isn't value for money for the
student this is rather a popular
complaint now because when we got the
so-called top-up fees by which students
contribute a bit of the cost of their
degrees retrospectively some people
started to say well students have become
customers i think that's ludicrous
when someone else pays most of the tab
one doesn't think one's really a
customer
the new fees are very modest
they don't cover the cost of the degree
they don't cover the cost of some
degrees by a really long way
payment is postponed until after
graduation even then it's income
contingent
interest rates are zero in real terms
if you earn very little the loan's
eventually forgiven can anyone think of
a better bargain
a more serious thought might be well
it's a jolly good bargain for the
students but it's a lousy bargain for
the taxpayer the taxpayers are still
contributing a huge cost of everyone's
degree however
much they're going to earn however much
their parents do earn
and we can all think of degrees that
we'd be awfully keen not to subsidize
but would you be prepared to argue for a
differential subsidy for different sorts
of degrees that may happen
finally what about the 50 target
yes the target is absurd
but the reason it's absurd is that
setting targets for things you don't
manage and can't control is absurd going
to university is something people choose
to do to do this subject that subject
and so on the target culture past its
prime but dying slowly pretends that
these things are centrally managed
so universities are greatly afflicted
with bizarre targets but remember
scotland is past 50
already are they really so much brighter
than those who live down here
england is far below it still
and nobody's going to be sure whether
the target's met because it's a target
for 18 to 30 year olds how do you
measure it perhaps that was the one
intelligent bit of this target so i
would urge everybody to get real and
vote against the motion
[Applause]
[Music]
the next speaker for the motion
is german nicholas
if you look at your song sheet you will
find she's described
simply as a pupil of symbols girls
school
um
to be a little more adequate
uh what she would like to do before she
becomes prime minister is to edit the
guardian
um
jenna
[Applause]
[Music]
good evening ladies and gentlemen fellow
panel members chairman
when i was asked to participate in this
debate at such a historic venue and with
such prestigious panel members
i turn to my prime source of inspiration
lewis carroll's alice in wonderland
you may remember a point in the book
where everyone is running madly in all
directions
at one point dodo calls out
the race is over
and they all crowd round him panting and
asking
but who has won
the dodo sits for a long time with a
finger pressed against his forehead
trying to find an answer
at last he says
everybody has one
and all must have prizes
like the dodo
tony blair's clarion call of education
education education
taps into the same philosophy that all
must have prizes
also the title of a book by melanie
phillips on education
this evening i would like to support the
proposition that too many people go to
university with three main points
firstly government targets on entrance
into university
are merely a numbers game destroying the
meaning and integrity of education
secondly many students in university
will be better suited to vocational
training
and thirdly too many graduates are
entering the workforce without being
able to find employment
so to my first point
government targets on entrance into
university have become merely a numbers
game
a long long time ago in the 1960s
going to university was reserved for a
privileged academic elite drawn from
approximately 30 percent of school
leavers
they entered into one of only 30
universities then available
these students were literate and
numerate and grammatical errors were the
exception rather than the rule
quite the country today
we live in a post-modernist culture
where subjectivism has taken the place
of academic rigor and systematic
teaching
the me culture as it has been named has
taken over
we are working towards a government
inclusiveness policy to get 50 of school
leavers by 2010 into one of over 200
institutions now offering degree courses
the problem is as a report by oxford
university and newcast revealed
freshman students have such poor skills
that some courses are having to be
extended by a whole year to redress the
gaps in basic education
in the name of egalitarianism
and to make statistics look good all
sorts of measures have been introduced
a levels are too difficult
no problem make them easier
universities are elitist
solution bringing a higher quality of
students from state schools
inadequate basic english and math skills
no problem the universities will teach
them
inadequate learning skills and general
knowledge
easy lower the standard of university
degrees
to return to alice in wonderland give
everyone prizes whether or not they
merit them
the emphasis on quantity rather than
quality covers up the basic failure of
the education policy
it is in fact an exercise in deception
to my second point many students in
universities will be better suited to
vocational training
professors and business owners alike
complain about the quality of university
students and graduates
we should perhaps therefore question the
wisdom of packing ever more students
into these institutions
after all what is the point of
university degrees such as surf and
beach management tourism and golf course
management
what is the point of granting
polytechnics the right to award degrees
perhaps we should rethink our education
policy entirely
why not look to our continental
neighbours
in germany and switzerland
as well as having trains that run on
time
children are separated at the age of 11
or 14.
at this point they have the option of
choosing a high quality vocational
training program
this is backed by government and
industry with maximum flexibility
to allow students to move from one
pathway to another
the academies introduced by the blair
government are a step in the right
direction but are still limited in their
scope
we shouldn't have to rely on eastern
europeans for our plumbers and
electricians
what is so important about going to
university anyway
mr blair says that we must invest in
human capital to survive in the global
economy
but alison wolfe professor of education
at king's college london argues that
university degrees are not necessary for
economic growth
she says
switzerland is one of the richest
economies in europe and yet has one of
the lowest number of graduates
and incidentally the highest number of
cows
there are after all many examples of
successful millionaires who left school
at the age of 16
richard branson and alan sugar to name
just two
to my final point too many graduates are
entering the workforce without being
able to find employment
three possible reasons for this are
firstly the number of university
students around 2.5 million has risen by
almost 50 percent over the past decade
this inevitably means that competition
for jobs requiring graduates is enormous
and unemployment amongst them high
secondly many graduates are a
disappointment to employers
a report published last year by the
association of graduate recruiters found
that almost half of the top 200
employers were disappointed by the
caliber of these candidates
and thirdly graduate skills are not what
all employers are looking for
philip green chairman of arcadia for
example will prefer to employ 16 year
olds he has found them easier to train
than graduate students
he says you don't have to have
qualifications to have common
sense this view is echoed by the owner
of a large retail chain in the audience
this evening i won't embarrass him by
mentioning his name
to conclude if england is to maintain
its well-deserved reputation for
providing excellent universities of a
high standard it must not let numerical
targets get in the way of those high
standards
we must crack down on the destructive
assumption that a university degree is
the only qualification that matters
and invests significantly in vocational
and apprenticeship training as a
distinct alternative to achievement and
pride
in this way all will have prizes but the
prize will match the talent capacity and
skill of that person and will not be
devalued to fit the philosophy
i therefore urge you to support the
proposition that too many people go to
university
thank you
the second speaker against the motion
is equally a student at saint paul's
her name is cece
marco giannis
and
when
she leaves
education
the likelihood after being prime
minister
is that she will edit the times
cece
[Applause]
[Music]
chairman
ladies and gentlemen
tonight i'm here to explain why it is
that there are not too many people going
to university and why we actually need
more students emerging with degrees
benjamin israeli once told the house of
commons a university should be a place
of light of liberty and of learning and
although some may discuss whether all of
today's universities match that
description
the university remains a vitally
important symbol of civilization
furthering knowledge educating and
providing a vital stage in citizens
lives they can learn enough to keep them
thinking long after they graduate
i will argue that we need more people
going to university for three key
reasons firstly because university gives
individuals a chance to improve
themselves
secondly by improving individuals
university creates improvements in
society and economy
but perhaps most importantly because
knowledge and entertainment of knowledge
should be valued by and for themselves
i do not believe that the proposition
would want to argue that no one should
attend university or at all universities
should be resolved and abolished like
the monetary is under henry viii
so in essence this debate is a numbers
game
aimed to discover if universities should
be rationed whether we in britain can
afford students and whether or not we
need lots of educated people
so just before i leap into the core of
my argument i'd like to pose a question
at what point would there be too many
people going to university really for
there to be too many we would need to be
at a stage where university no longer
better individuals or society and
conversely caused more of a negative
effect than a positive one
society would have to be ridden with
flexibly trained people the extent that
it was oversaturated
people would have to be too perfectly
informed an understanding of the society
in which they live
we would have to live in a country where
millions of educated people were
stranded on oxford street holding
cardboard banners reading will translate
latin for pennies
or will demonstrate complex mathematical
proofs in exchange for sandwiches
and
we're not there yet
a holder of a university degree and
significantly more on average than a
similar individual with two or more a
levels and these higher earnings bring
significant economic benefits not only
in the higher taxes they pay but also in
the jobs they create for others
so with the numbers of celebrity big
brother viewers rivaling native educated
citizens i think it would be safe to say
that we can afford a slightly more
intellectual society
there is still room for improvement and
[Music]
and room for those who value a degree
going back to that word improvement it
sounds very new labor
actually it is very much what britain
has been working towards since the start
of the 20th century and it leads me onto
my first key point
university gives individuals a chance to
improve themselves
because university offers the chance for
a better life and a more fulfilled one
every person of every ability level
deserves opportunity should they choose
it to attend a university
they should have a right to it we should
not be trying to curb the education of
the masses but conversely should be
actively motivated in trying to ensure
that everyone reaches as far as they can
it is undeniable this country's
class-dominated history has wasted great
talent in the past through
discrimination
it was only relatively recently that the
other 50 percent women were given the
chance to really prove themselves
since the suffragettes fight for
political quality we've seen incredible
achievements by women benefiting from
education
leaders of countries such as chile india
germany argentina britain not to mention
all the great writers scientists and
business women education has made that
possible
also it was not so long ago that it
would have been unthinkable for the
child of working class parents to enter
higher education and reach his or her
full potential
education has made this possible
for the individual university is the
surest route for upward mobility
in order to promise the possibility of a
better life there can never be too many
individuals going to university
socrates once said and we shall begin by
educating mind and character shall we
not for the development of a whole
person it comes not just from knowledge
but from experience and the chance to be
inspired by elders and peers the chance
to be integrated into the community of
university also teaches students
valuable life lessons at a time when the
community building roles of the church
and military haven't really been
replaced
university can be seen as a transitional
portal between a sheltered family life
centered on the individual's instinctive
needs
and that individual taking their place
as a full member of a wider society who
takes responsibility and recognizes the
consequences of his or her actions
the late howard bowen former president
of the state university of iowa and an
authority on university education speaks
in his thesis the investment of learning
of universities as kind of industry
within themselves
the input being malleable willing
students and the output being an
informed individual ready to take their
place within society
and this leads me onto my second key
point by improving individuals
university creates improvements in
society and economy
important as the individuals benefits
from university may be when looking at
the wider picture the progress of
individuals is progress for society both
their economic value and their
understanding of social practice
a u.s study has shown that among nearly
2 600 people between the ages of 18 and
30 the lowest concentration of active
voters occurred amongst those who had
never attended higher education they
should not be surprising
given the privilege of living in a
democratic country people should be
allowed the means to fully utilize the
influence they have over how the taxes
are spent and this can only happen
through education
as school virgil noted half of the
american people have never read
newspaper
half never vote for president
one hopes is the same half
[Applause]
now we are also needing of university
educated assistance not just for the
sake of society but also for the sake of
our economy some journalists and
commentators have suggested that this is
untrue but if you think rationally it is
clear that the future will reward
countries with an educated workforce by
2012 it has been estimated 50 percent of
positions are most likely to demand
university graduates although labour may
be backing down on its ambitious gold 50
university rate the fact still remains
that we need educated workers
a few other countries have already
reached a 50 university attendance
rating and we're only at 43 percent
university ready the next generation and
when times and industries change rapidly
we need to make like girl scouts and
always be prepared
the best bet to be prepared is to have a
flexible workforce chameleon-like and
its adaptability to changing
circumstances and university education
gives individuals that flexibility
in case anyone fail to notice the world
is changing
we're leaving behind an industrial
economy and progressing into the service
and knowledge economies and size is
catching up with us we can't expect to
compete with countries on the scale of
india and china in the assembly
businesses if we're not careful we won't
be able to compete in any business
leaving educated staff either
we're no longer the world's leaders in
education
we're not the world leaders in much
anymore really and for the simple reason
of size and numbers the numbers game
doesn't work too well for us britain is
a small country compared to india or
china and will be lost if we don't
realize that we too must develop instead
of resting on the laurels of our past
successes
investing in the future means seriously
investing in the people who run it the
students of today
be it feasible grants seem that there is
no better investment and the only
problem that i see is not enough money
being put in not too many students
now i'll come to my final point and the
point that i feel is most important that
university encourages the kind of
knowledge value in society we want and
that learning in itself should be raised
on a higher pedestal than it is at
currently
even forgetting the future and the
real-time benefits of university let's
look to the past and the present i'm
glad that socrates wasn't alive to hear
pink floyd we don't need no education
because we do we really do education
gives us so much i'm glad that socrates
isn't here now to witness the truly
shameful position that knowledge holds
in the priority pyramids of the masses
crammed under the pile um of reality tv
shopping money even success falls into
that category
sure a graduate's degree can get you the
credentials for a great job get you a
nice house a nice life help society help
the economy all good things of course
but it will also offer a currency that
no one can deny you wisdom and knowledge
and there is no greater thing than to
learn for knowledge is power
according to socrates himself the only
good is knowledge and the only evil is
ignorance so to get universities
affected on the economy and on society
if you wish just remember that
university need not simply be a means to
an end
it can and should be a place of light of
liberty and of learning today it would
be a huge mistake deny a single person
of the right to university if they wish
to be given the chance
so because university still has a lot to
give everyone i beg you to oppose the
motion too many people go into
university thank you
[Applause]
the third and final speaker for the
motion
is anton konecki
it's a very times oriented
second half
of the program
but we welcome you for nine minutes
[Applause]
[Music]
well uh
that last speech is a very hard act to
follow i think you'll all agree uh but
it's particularly hard i think for me to
follow because i've got to make a
confession which is that i disagree with
my colleagues on the right hand side uh
i disagree with for claire fox in the
sense that i do have a rose tinted view
of universities i'm quite in favor of
social engineering
and i'm not really all that much against
dumbing down after all i do work for the
times in tabloid form
[Applause]
[Music]
and
what's more than that i i have a little
secondary career uh which is explaining
economics to hedge fund managers
so
i can't say i've got anything against
dumbing down on the other hand listening
to this side of the table i've got to
say uh that like baroness o'neill and
even more eloquently cece i really do
believe that knowledge should be valued
in and of itself i like to live in an
intellectual even a socratic society and
actually also i think that everybody
should have prizes like the dodo so what
am i doing arguing on that side of the
debate
well normally i would be able to give a
very simple answer which would be as i'm
an economist after all which would be to
say well that side paid me more than
this site
but i can't do that today because we all
know this evening is for the benefit of
saint paul's girls school
uh so let me try and come up with some
more cogent arguments well starting with
uh some numbers as i say as an economist
in 1900 when clement and i were just
young children
one percent of the population went to
university by 1950 the percentage was up
to three percent in britain by
by the mid 90s 30 percent
40 percent now and by 2010 we have a
target of of 50
now if any of you who know about
economics financial markets and so on if
you see a chart rising and then
accelerating at this uh
stratospheric economic exponential rate
the first thing you do is start asking
some questions the second is you put a
good hand on your wallet because you
feel you your one's instinct is to
believe that there must be something
wrong and excessive and speculative
going on particularly when you look
around the world and you you see as has
already been mentioned that the rate of
university graduates is now much higher
in britain than it is not only
switzerland but in germany france italy
even sweden in america it's true that
they send slightly more people into
tertiary education but their system is
clearly divided between four-year
academic colleges like our universities
and two-year community colleges which
have no pretensions at all of offering
academic-style degrees
so does it make sense to have the 40
percent that we now have going to
university and even more emphatically i
would question this 50 percent target
now the obvious question to ask as i say
as an economist is is it wasteful well
probably it is but actually who cares
surely it is worth while giving people
the opportunity to enjoy the university
experience to uh sample the socratic
intellectualism that we've talked about
not to mention three years of sex drugs
and rock and roll uh i'm all in favor of
that and as a taxpayer i'm actually
quite willing to pay for it
my worry
for others as well as for myself
and my children
my worry is not that these universities
are wasteful but that actually it this
rate of university expansion could be
positively harmful
both to the students and to society at
large
and what i'm going to do is just briefly
talk about four potential harms that i
think in fourth categories to the
students themselves to the economy more
broadly to universities and then to
society as a whole well starting with
students themselves dropout and failure
rates are now as high as 30 percent in
many
new universities and former polytechnics
now we have many complaints and i think
we've heard we've heard already in this
debate about the money wasted on
university fees by dissolution
students which are substantial sums now
but these losses are a fraction of the
real costs of are going to university
for students who then don't graduate or
who find that they're wasting the time
the real cost consists of course not
just of the fees but of the income and
the time that they have forgone over
three two or three years
and that's usually at least 10 times
what the fees cost them after all even a
non-university graduate can expect to
earn round about 20 000 pounds a year so
a three-year university course
potentially costs them 60 000 pounds
even more importantly the personal
discouragement that is suffered uh which
is almost impossible to calculate by
people who go to university and find
that what they're doing there doesn't
suit them worst of all is that
universities can deflect people from
occupations and lifestyles that actually
suit them and they would find
interesting and rewarding
sports shopkeeping plumbing and divert
them into activities which are often
pointless
and not rewarding at all for example
sports sciences retail psychotherapy and
human waste logistics
that one i made up i've got to make
those
but if you think about it that's what
plumbing is
from an act from a from an academic
standpoint so
the students themselves not all not the
majority but a significant number of
students themselves i think are harmed
by going to university not to mention
the anti-intellectual attitudes that
actually that will generate in those who
go to university and find that it's
completely unsuitable for them and has
not prepared them for the lives that
they're seeking next what does it do to
the economy to potential employers and
to the customers to to the people
so to the consumers so people on both
sides of the economy well university has
become a system of sifting rather than
education now that's actually nothing
new in fact even when i was at
university uh my tutor told me uh you
know just just um after i'd done my
third year uh my final exams uh before i
got my results he said well don't you
realize i said well you know have i been
educated adequately have you done enough
to teach me uh to get a decent degree
and he said don't you realize you're not
here to be taught you're here to be
sifted and i think that was always true
but the problem is that when you get to
a sifting point of 40 or 50 percent what
you are doing is is sifting people on
the basis of high level analytical
skills or numerical analysis which is
simply inappropriate for deciding uh the
40 percent of the population who have to
go or who who most of whom will will go
into occupations that don't take
advantage of those skills whether it's
retail management fire fighting or even
social work police army officers it's
not clear that they need the kind of
academic skills that universities are
designed to teach moreover there's a
serious risk of the creation of over of
an over qualification syndrome it's
actually made it harder for our society
to train nurses primary teachers
veterinarians sports coaches personal
trainers increasingly even plumbers and
gardeners that has all been made more
difficult by the creation of these new
tiers of skills it's been estimated by
alison wolfe who's already been quoted
that between 25 and 30 percent of the
jobs that are now confined by law to
graduates only have have experienced no
changes at all in the level of academic
skills required to do them there's been
this proliferation of qualifications uh
two years ago you may even have read the
story about the headmaster of
westminster who is not allowed on his
retirement who is a mathematics teacher
through for 40 years career at
westminster who was not allowed after
his retirement to teach mathematics in a
comprehensive school when he felt he
wanted to give something back to society
because he didn't have the appropriate
bed qualifications
and many of the skills that are in
shorter supply in our society today are
actually non-intellectual which isn't to
say that the people doing them are
stupid or are likely to be underpaid in
america the occupational category uh as
defined by the department of employment
in a survey done about two years ago
which they reckoned had the best
employment
prospects and the highest income growth
potential over the next 15 years was
personal training
plumbing gardening catering elderly care
all these are increasingly important
occupations but they don't necessarily
benefit from book learning
uh sorry i've i've run out of times you
can see i didn't go to a school for
rhetoric either my third point was which
i'll be very brief about is that
universities themselves have also
suffered from the
mass production mentality from the
decline in academic salaries as
obviously facilities have had to be
expanded to deal with larger numbers but
frankly i think that's the argument one
hears most of and i care least about
because we're not here to uh create more
privileges for university teachers the
fourth and most important of my argument
for which i have no time but i'm going
to encroach anyway is what it's done for
education and society first of all
there's the diversion of resources to
university teaching from the rest of the
of the educational system the fact is
that the real failures of britain's
british education have not been in
universities not even in the grammars
and comprehensive they're in the
education of the bottom 10 or 20 percent
of the population the underclass and
these are precisely the people who are
becoming ever more disillusioned than
even feral as the education system
increasingly abandons them and the
opportunities for manufacturing manual
non-academic kind of labor dwindle
now this is bad enough when you've got
40 going to university
but what will happen when 50 percent go
what symbol i think the symbolism of
this is crucial when more than half the
when when more than half the population
as at present attempt the universe
attend the university of life instead of
oxford they can regard themselves as the
normal success successful respectable
middle while the academic minority is a
small subgroup of society albeit a
privileged one but once the academic
minority becomes a majority what signal
does this send
that there are that those who do not go
to university are social rejects and
failure that they are a minority
oppressed by the privileged upper class
nothing could be more divisive more
damaging to social cohesion and
destruction of human initiative and
talent
human enterprise and talent are
infinitely varied trying to squeeze half
the population into a straight jacket of
arbitrary academic uh
education
is the surest way of destroying this
infinite diversity of talent enterprise
and hope thank you very much
[Applause]
the final speaker against the motion
marianne seaguard
[Music]
thank you
let's start with a very quick experiment
can i please ask you to put your hand up
either if you didn't go to college or
university and you don't regret it a bit
or if you're of school age and you're
sure that you don't want to go to
university or any other college
thank you well as i suspected a very
very small minority of this audience and
the rest of you know about the great
benefits that you got from going to
university or if you're still at school
you look forward to them and who are we
to deprive anyone else of that benefit
as long as they have the ability to gain
from it
now my oldest in both centers of the
word friend bill deeds is still at the
venerable age of 93 saw about the fact
that the crash of 1929 bankrupted his
father and deprived him of the chance of
a university education
only the other day he told me about
going to a job interview at the times
when he was a young man
which college were you at was the first
question put to him by the interviewer
who was used to being surrounded only by
oxbridge alumni
poor bill slunk out of the room
luckily the daily telegraph wasn't so
intellectually snobbish and has had the
benefit of bill's wonderful writing for
the last 75 years
but the times still expects its graduate
trainees to have won a first-class
degree from a first-class university
and our workplace is just a microcosm of
the wider economy
jobs that used to be filled by school
leavers have become more demanding and
now call for graduates
an airplane that used to be able to be
mended with a screwdriver and a spanner
now has highly complex systems and
technology that can be mastered only by
a technician with an engineering degree
our economy is changing fast it needs
higher level skills than it used to
if our schools and universities don't
produce enough highly skilled people
we're all going to lose out
there are fewer and fewer unskilled jobs
these days and fewer manual jobs as our
manufacturing industries are overtaken
by lower-cost competitors like china
in today's globalized world a high-wage
country like britain can compete only if
it has a highly educated workforce doing
challenging jobs
now i find it odd that we're even
treating this as a contentious issue
look at the most economically successful
nations of the past decade ireland india
and china what do they have in common a
highly educated workforce
we may be increasing the proportion of
people who go to university but we're
not doing it nearly as fast as our
competitors
a recent oecd study found that the uk
was slipping fast down the league table
which measured the percentage of people
getting degrees in 2000 we were second
by 2003 we were eight
between 95 and 2003 our participation in
higher education rose by 20
and the rest of the oecd the average
rise was 38
in other words we're increasing
participation at university only half as
fast as our competitors are if anything
we're being left behind
now you might say that universities are
teaching the wrong things as some of our
opponents have said and you might be
right
in fact the opponents of this argument
tend to use just two words and then sit
back and smirk
golf studies they say
but actually very few people do a degree
in gulf studies and of those who do all
of them get jobs
in our
in our aging and increasingly prosperous
and bourgeois society there is more
money to spend on golf and leisure and
more demand for intelligent people to
run these leisure facilities
learning how to run a successful golf
course and its associated businesses is
just like doing the first half of an mba
with a particular emphasis on one
section of the leisure industry
actually we ought to be offering more
vocational degrees what are often known
as foundation degrees like the community
colleges in the us do
for it's here that the biggest skills
gap exists
these two-year degrees won't have the
same cachet as the full three-year
honours degree and that's quite right
they're doing a different job
we need to keep our centers of
excellence our oxfords and cambridges
and london's but for the bottom third of
students we should redesign what is a
rather clunking 20th century model of
university education to offer degrees
that are shorter cheaper more flexible
and closer to home
so yes i agree with claire that
universities need reforming
but that's not the same as saying that
too many people go to them
in fact there are two cast iron measures
of determining whether too many people
go the rate of unemployment of graduates
and the pay they get after they graduate
if too many people went to university
there wouldn't be enough jobs for them
to enter afterwards
and in fact i'm afraid to say jen is
quite wrong about this graduate
unemployment is minuscule it's just 2.7
which is less than half the non-graduate
rate of unemployment
and if too many people went to
university their salaries after
graduation wouldn't be high enough to
compensate them for the costs of three
years study
in fact the premium earned by graduates
over what a non-graduate would expect to
earn is well over a hundred thousand
pounds
and it's the highest in the oecd
particularly for women poor liners
please note
what's more now that people have to pay
out for their own higher education we
can easily measure whether they feel
it's worth it why would you spend 9
thousand pounds on fees plus another
fifteen or twenty thousand pounds on
living expenses if you didn't think you
could more than recoup that some in
higher earnings
and these decisions are not just being
made by eighteen-year-olds a million
undergraduates about 40 percent of the
total a mature student studying
part-time
they must have calculated that a degree
is worth their while or they wouldn't be
doing it or paying for it
and if all this sounds rather dryly
economic and materialistic then let's
look at the more human benefits of more
people going to university
those of you who've been yourselves will
know that university broadens the mind
education for education's sake as cece
said is it worthwhile good in itself
it's good for society too
surveys show that graduates tend to be
more involved in society they volunteer
more they're more socially liberal and
they're more tolerant
so if we hate what's been going on on
celebrity brig brother we should support
more people going to university
and on top of that university graduates
are in general happier and healthier
they live longer they're less of a
burden on the nhs what's not to like
and if we want this for ourselves and
for our children which we all do then we
shouldn't pull up the drawbridge to less
deprived sorry more deprived but just as
intelligent children
at the moment universities are a middle
class enclave
of 18 year olds from the top three
social classes go and only 15
of the bottom two
now you may believe the iq distribution
is skewed towards the top end but it
can't be that skewed
if we want more bright but poor children
to have the leg up that university
offers we have two choices
either our children have to make way for
them no thanks
or we expand the university intake to
provide places for them i know which
option i'd prefer
and if you believe that too many people
go to university as the opposition claim
you've got to be prepared for entry to
become much more competitive with the
chance that your own children will lose
out
so to sum up
university education is good for the
economy in fact it's absolutely
necessary for the economy
it's good for the people who go and
expansion of the numbers creates a
fairer and more meritocratic society
but best of all it's a civilizing
influence on society we should have more
of it not less
if you would vote for shil pachetti
rather than jade goody you should vote
against the motion
[Applause]
thank you very much
on arrival
you were asked to
imply how you would vote
before you had the debate
and the result of the roughly 800 people
who were here
was that
458 were for the motion
too many people go to university
144 were against
and 120
didn't know
but i'm pretty sure we'll know now
um
we are going to have questions which can
be either directed to
individuals of this top table
the table which is wonderfully
comprehensive in
having an age range
of 65 years between the eldest and the
youngest
which is unusual
although as as you say um
age is unimportant
i mean my
my favorite proposal used to be
will you come upstairs and make love to
me
and now i have to say one or the other
i would like
to ask people
when they put their questions
to
preface their questions with
whether or not they have been to
university
so perhaps
when you wave and somebody with a
microphone will come along and let you
speak you will begin by stating your
name
and saying been
or not been
the being being university
uh our microphone ladies ready
yeah
change sex but ready
um
questions
sir
blue church in the middle
hang on a moment until my friend gets to
thank you my name is dante malegrino and
i'm italian i've not only been at
university i've also got a phd so
my question is for people in favor of
the motion now you've mentioned quite a
few times people doing
doing low-skilled jobs like people from
eastern europe and so on uh how do you
what's your comment about people like
myself who are clearly not great and
come to england because there is a
there's a need for people with high
qualification graduate people to do
these type of jobs
would you represent this
i'm happy to take it um
our education secondary and university
is very defective particularly in uh the
teaching of uh foreign languages
consequently we have to do a lot of
importing the european union is
fantastic because it makes it easy to do
this but it's a bit shaming
yes i think i think the question i i
think he agrees with you anyways
i think the question was directed to us
uh i think uh the the i think the the
fact that britain
brings in all these people uh is simply
a reflection of the
uh
wide distribution of talent around the
world and uh however good our education
system is
and actually at the top at the elite
level it is extremely good still by uh
but by any standard certainly compared
with the university system in the rest
of europe according to the you know most
of the
league tables of uh international
universities there are only three
universities in europe that are graded
within the top 20 and they're all in
britain
uh but however good our education system
is we are not going to find and train
the most brilliant people in the world
most of the most brilliant people in the
world
live in the rest of the world we're only
two percent of the population and so if
we have an economy and particularly a
business community particularly
financial community that's open to that
that's uh that increases its strength so
i don't think it reflects on the
education system yeah
most europe most european plumbers i uh
east european plumbers and builders i
know have got phds and the thing that's
uh fascinating is they're treated like
dirt as immigrants which is terrible and
uh and end up taking uh um those kind of
jobs in some instances but i just wanted
to say something about this increasing
tenancy in in some of the contributions
which is that there are people who are
naturally uh the type of people who
should do vocational courses and we all
know who we mean
right and i just think who do you mean i
mean the idea that 11 or 12 or 13 or 14
you can decide that somebody is going to
be a vocational type effectively means
abandoning educating them and what i
would suggest is that we should educate
people in good faith for as long as
possible and what's happening is that
you're going to university now and not
getting that education you're actually
getting vocational skills training and
that is not education all plumbers
should be educated as well as any
philosopher everybody deserves a decent
education but they're just not getting
it just because they're going to
university we shouldn't be conned
[Music]
uh do we have a microphone upset
hello
another question
we'll have it in the aisle here
who would like to be the next one after
this
get a microphone to the work yes
i was selfishly going to ask anatole
calendar
yes i was going to ask anatoletsky to
give us the benefit of the
censored bit that he was unable to
deliver before because i enjoyed it a
great deal and i wanted to hear more
about it
wait for my summing up
back
hello
uh graham archer um yes university far
too long
i'm another one of these unpopular phds
everyone hates people with phds
i don't know why i'm completely in favor
of the motion i thought claire fox in
particular was fantastic and as a
statistician it strikes me that it's
difficult to be in faith against the
motion and not willfully wish to
decrease the quality of the further
education if you accept that there's a
natural variation in people's ability in
any particular discipline and you
increase the number of people who are
being admitted to study that discipline
i don't think you need induction i think
it's fairly deductively obvious that
you're going to have to decrease the
standards of the education that you give
them
otherwise you have to accept that
everyone's getting bright and brighter
all the time and i just don't just very
quickly miss seeker asked us to put our
hand off if we didn't have an education
and my partner keith here was one of the
very few people who had the honesty of
the nerve to put us outside of
university education he then said um we
need people with qualifications from
universities to do things like bm
engineers for aircraft and stuff
keith's a very brilliant engineer and he
learned how to do that through 16 years
in the royal air force
i don't think that three years at the
university of north london studying
whatever would have made him a better
engineer nor do i think we could have
been better as a society had he done
soon
[Applause]
uh good evening
chairman and very distinguished members
of the panel
now no one could attract me or my
applause no one i'm no fan but i i take
my hat off to all of you and
particularly uh you know this wonderful
creature claire fox and i really mean
that sincerely i ain't no fan let me
ventilate this for you could we have
your question this it's so simple
thank you chairman you'll get it very
decidedly
um
right now here and now
let me tell you to your face i had the
misfortune to be at cambridge
what an ordeal and when i was living in
the albany chambers up the road here
with my mother and that hideous note
dropped through the door saying that i'd
want a place at cambridge my edward
edwardian grandmother said there's only
one thing to do with it tear it up in a
thousand pieces which we did but i
fortuned to be at cambridge and during
the time that uh the little pigeon-toed
snake who the cambridge
uh lord snowden and lord owen and they
and i'm telling you now education is
only for the few and
hey
definitely not
and as mighty tongue said to these proud
academics grab a hoe and till a little
bit of the soil that's what they should
be doing
the next question
[Applause]
as long as it's not contagious
my name is i did go to you in a manner
um
my question originated at the opponents
of the motion um there's a lot of talk
about skill and what people would learn
and be up
what they learned at university
what my question is aren't there other
places where people can learn an awful
lot
does it have to be university
uh no it can be either at um further
education colleges or at university but
these new two-year foundation degrees
vocational degrees are actually um very
good for equipping people with the sort
of level of skills
that our economy needs these days and um
you know claire says oh we shouldn't be
teaching vocational skills at university
how snobbish is that why shouldn't we
[Applause]
i'm a member i'm a graduate of the open
university and i would like to know what
the panel thinks about distance
education and its value
and what they think about it please
thank you
who would like to answer this
nobody
i will
think i think the open apparently is the
most wonderful institution
i'm i'm a great fan of the open
university as well but the only thing
that i would say is that
a lot of uh university teaching now is
quite distant and because actually um
[Music]
first of all everybody's kind of into
teaching via um new technology and so
there's this idea that you kind of don't
have to have face-to-face contact on the
one hand and there's kind of a big fuss
about um how you don't actually need to
new ways of learning and so on that's
not to get at the open university um but
i just think that we should bear in mind
that the open university itself has
started to go down a rather illiberal
route and are talking about being
business facing teaching skills and so
on so even the wonderful open university
i'm afraid has fallen for the recent
orthodoxies
um we'll have a question over here now
hello yes thank you um i've been to four
different universities i'm an
ex-secondary teacher and i also now
teach in higher education and i wonder
whether the question shouldn't be
about the inflation of qualifications
and whether the motion shouldn't be
is university any longer enough
because certainly in the postgraduate
sector it's no longer enough to have one
degree and in many occupations you need
a degree a master's level degree and
then further qualification and study
after that and i wonder whether either
side of the panel might comment on that
that's a good point
anybody well i i think actually that's a
symptom of the uh widening of
universities that we've been talking
about i mean the fact that a first
degree no longer qualifies you for an
academic or in fact even a scholastic
teaching profession i think is an
indication of
how
the
what a first degree is per se has been
diluted it doesn't mean that all first
degrees have been diluted i think the
degrees of the elite universities are
still probably as demanding as ever uh
but it does mean that a universe a
degree in human waste logistics as i was
talking about is not the same as a
degree in classics or mathematics
uh
hello good evening i didn't go to
university and i'd like to ask the
people speaking against the motion to
comment on the dropout rate which is
people speaking four have commented is
reaching 30 certainly in some london
institutions surely that is the clearest
evidence that too many people are going
to university
i would say this the very few
institutions they are mainly in london
with that sort of dropout rate this is a
completely anomalous one there are other
universities where the dropout rate is
extraordinarily low by international
standards right down to one or two
percent
it is definitely the case that it is new
universities with a higher dropout rates
now does it mean that it is all without
value the americans who pioneered mass
higher education would say no
even the person who does a year
may gain a great deal from it though
they don't go as far as a degree
and i've known people who for all sorts
of reasons often health family finance
reasons didn't get to the end of a
degree but would say that they got a lot
so i find it hard to generalize but i
think that institutions with that sort
of dropout rate have got a problem and
it's no good setting targets to improve
it guess what that incentivizes
thank you
questions
with some leap on their hand
grab a microphone over there
uh thank you uh my name is uh alan
murray jones and i am a uh i am a
university graduate uh from uh from
australia as it happens uh i just like
there are loads and loads of arguments
on both sides but it's like to touch on
the economic argument that uh miss
seahart used uh or one of the economic
arguments was that um
the lifetime income of graduates will be
a hundred thousand pounds higher than uh
than the lifetime uh income of
non-graduates on average just asked to
like to ask mr kalecki if i
spend
ten thousand pounds on going to
university
and i incur additional costs of 60 000
pounds in income foregone
and i do that between the ages of 18 and
20.
am i better off getting another 100 000
over the next 40 years
well i i i think you've answered your
own question
you're not uh but i i think to be fair
to marianne i think the kind of
calculations that she was quoting uh
what i i think they they actually
conclude that even taking all those
factors into account uh the present
value as it were of the additional
income generated over a lifetime is the
hundred thousand pounds i think i think
you're perfectly right that if all you
could get is a hundred thousand pounds
in cash uh in total over a 40-year
working lifetime by going to university
it would be very bad value from an
economic point of view although as i
said i still have a rose tinted view and
would say it's well worth it if uh
you can enjoy the intellectual life and
the sex drugs and rock and roll but
uh question over there
we can't hear you
perhaps the microphone would be a help
it would be a hell uh i went to art
college not to university um but it
would probably be a degree course now
if you talk to a lot of graduates
undergraduates who are doing art courses
at university they're very bored they
only have about seven or eight lectures
a week
and i wonder whether that might be
something to do with a high dropout rate
what does the panel think
well i i think there's there's a degree
of boredom i think now that it's not we
don't want to get into the numbers game
either in terms of how many hours you
get there's just been a big report which
sort of tries to say that the best
universities teach more hours
and i think that's treating university
like school i think that though going to
university now is boring because people
aren't being intellectually challenged
and in fact it's interesting that when
you talk to a lot of young people today
there is a real indifference about
university life there's a kind of like
oh it's all right it's like it's almost
like is this it then is this the
glittering prizes no wonder there's a
kind of oh god you know it's tiresome
it's boring it's routine it's banal it's
contracted out it's not the
exciting intellectually stimulating
place of the socratic ideal that people
keep talking about the only places where
that exists is at a very small number of
universities and what we're in danger of
doing now is effectively saying well you
know oxbridge and london are all right
and everybody else can go for two-year
foundation courses everywhere else and
they'll be all right won't they so
actually what we've got now is a less
a much more elitist anti-meritocratic
anti-egalitarian atmosphere disguising
itself as anti-elitism with all the
self-righteousness of people who say i
want everyone to go to university but
oxford and cambridge and london are all
right for those special subjects for my
children and everyone else can go to the
dogs and it's not good enough and it's
intolerable to hear people use the term
uh university so promiscuously because
it does nobody a favor and it's actually
against the intellectualism that we
would want universities to encourage
[Applause]
and you're next
i find myself very confused as to what
is meant by university
both sides seem to be using it in a way
that
suits their case particularly those
against the idea of people going to
university
seemed to be talking about further
education
as if that was university
and surely there's a big distinction
between university
and further education not only to
generalize the government what is it
because the i mean i have been to
university myself
but i don't understand
the the terms in which you're talking
there's a mixture of idealism
uh apparent reality a blend of
statistics which we don't know exactly
where they come from
and one ends up very confused
as i'm sure a lot of young people are
today about whether they go to
university or not i think the government
has done his best to make everything
that is not a super casino a university
did you want to say
i think you've rumbled the debate
uh you're right
that uh and uh we shouldn't spend too
long disputing about terminology but
what is offending a lot of people is
that institutions that are not the sort
of institutions they went to they want
their children to go to are being called
universities and that lots of
institutions that have long delivered
important good vocational training have
been either incorporated into
universities art colleges are a good
example or affiliated with universities
offering foundation degrees i think
there's a good thought experiment if you
think that fewer people should go to
university how far would you like to
pull the label back do you want the
label to go to two percent of
institutions
that tertiary institutions
so that
post-school institutions and your own
children probably won't get there
five percent
just see how far feels attractive to you
how far feels safe
uh thank you we'll have one question
from upstairs then we'll come to you
thanks um i'm claire jackson i also went
to art college and i just want to
comment on what claire fox was saying
about the
lack of rigor in universities
i i know an awful lot of students
undergraduates i work in education fully
supporting the government's aim higher
policy which has been tremendously
successful
and there is enormous rigor in the
universities i have two daughters who
are undergraduates they're very
particular about deadlines and standards
and it's grossly unfair to
um
dismiss
the work the excellent work that's going
on in our universities and i'm not just
talking about london university or
oxford cambridge
we have many we have many excellent
universities doing a superb job with
very high standards
thank you
[Applause]
my name is jeffrey lloyd
i did not go to university and my
question is directed primarily to the
proposes of the motion
implicit in the motion is the idea of
going to university at the age of 18.
i wonder if those supporting the motion
would modify their views
if it were possible to enable many more
people to go to university when they're
older when perhaps they were more mature
and have gained some experience in the
world of work
[Applause]
uh one more question yes
over here
hello i i didn't go to university but
i'm an employer and i would like to ask
marianne segut what she would say to a
graduate who goes to
a second or third class university and
comes out with a second or third class
degree and who can't find a job what
would you say to him or her about their
expectations
well i think
i think you'll find that very very few
of them are in that situation actually
as i said it's only 2.7
and personally i still think they will
have benefited from the three years
education they'll have had at that
university
well i should think it's extremely
likely they will end up with a better
job than they would have had had they
had they gone into work straight from
school
thank you
um
we
we are now 12 minutes away from the end
of the debate
and each person
this top table i'm sorry it's too late
we'll do a one minute
or two minutes summing up
um i think we will do it in the
opposite order to which we began
one of the uh questioners down there was
kind enough to uh ask what else i might
have said if i had a few more minutes uh
that's precisely yeah
yeah
precisely what i want to do uh because
actually does uh touch on i think your
the mys is the most important point uh
in this debate which is that
uh the question of uh social mobility
and are we actually promoting or uh
damaging social mobility uh by the
decision to teach vocational skills what
are i think have generally been agreed
many of these are purely vocational
skills in the university environment and
this isn't just about plumbing when we
talk about vocational skills i think a
number of comments from people at art
college gave a very good example a lot
of people go to art college in order to
learn to be artists in order to paint to
do sculpture to do graphic design they
don't go to art college in order to
write essays about what it's like to be
artists and that is the trouble with
teaching art in a university environment
if we intellectualize all vocational
studies whether it's art or garden
plumbing golf catering and so on if we
demand that a waiter must get a degree
in catering studies in order to become a
sous chef or a chamber made must study
hospitality science to have any chance
of becoming a hotel manager then we're
actually denying ever more opportunities
to people who are less intellectual or
may simply be temperamentally
uninterested in theoretical learning but
they may well be very good at charming
customers inventing delicious sources or
taking business opportunities and i
think that is what we're losing by
redefining vocational education in this
socratic university context
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody's suggesting that chambermaids or
sous chefs should go to university
they're still we're only saying that
half the population should there are
still half the jobs left in the economy
that won't demand degrees and i'm afraid
to say that whether they mean to be or
not the supporters of this motion are
really snobs at heart
well
what they're saying is oh we don't want
these ghastly vocational degrees at our
universities we only want philosophy at
our universities well why shouldn't
universities teach vocational subjects
they're saying claire said oh we don't
want students to be consumers perish the
thought well i could they shouldn't fill
in forms saying if their professors are
any good or not i can remember when i
was at university my tutor used to pride
himself in being in giving such boring
lectures that he drove everyone away by
the fourth week of term so after that he
simply had to turn up check the room was
empty and he could go back to his rooms
again well i would quite like to have
been given a chance to comment on that
personally
and and most of all what they don't want
perish to thought is more working-class
people going to university because after
all if they no no no i mean it if you
want fewer people to go to university
which is what the supporters of the
nation say they want fewer people to go
to university who are going to be the
universities will become completely
dominated by middle class children we
all know that they are already
now
in in 1902 when the balfour act was
passed the great debate in the country
was where the working-class children
could even benefit from secondary school
now i'm afraid we're having that benefit
all over that debate all over again
we're pulling up the drawbridge and if
you disagree with that and you don't
feel that you're a snob then please vote
against the motion
[Applause]
let me just
explain that um it's too late
people are voting as you speak
um
it's too late to get your vote back
jenna
i think we must remember the point on
our side we're not saying that
vocational training shouldn't be allowed
we're saying that universities are not
the place for this vocational training
to take place so it's it's in the
polytechnics that we've already got rid
of
and also that the government targets on
trying to get more and more people into
university is actually destroying the
education that should be given to all
people and that this the education and
this knowledge that we want for everyone
this should be done in schools we
shouldn't have to rely on people to have
to go to university to get this
knowledge from that yeah thank you
[Applause]
i think where this debate has gone
slightly wrong is that it's become about
choosing quality or quantity and
although at present it seems that we
can't have both and have a good system
that works but what happens if we if we
choose quality if we choose quality then
we're going to be having to deny certain
people of the right university and then
who do we deny
thank you
the last time i was called a snob an
elitist and accused of pulling up the
drawbridge from the working class was
with a bunch of people in the media who
were arguing that tv is now democratized
the ordinary people are now given an
opportunity to be involved in tv and
anyone like me who argued against it was
a snob and an elitist and so on and so
forth guess who those people were they
were endemol they were the makers of big
brother and guess what by the way they
went to eaton and oxbridge right they
think that what ordinary people are like
or the people that they put in big
brother and what ordinary people deserve
is big brother they treat us with
contempt ordinary people should whether
and i love that you're a snobby um but
sheamus chambermaid and shoe chest we
don't want them to go to university i do
just not to study catering and making
beds but to discover to study medieval
history and philosophy and anything else
as arcane and as intellectually rigorous
as possible and finally i'm shocked by
laura o'neill who seems to imagine that
all we want to do is to go back to the
universities of the past i'm going to
show you i want to go back to where i
came from but anyway that's not the
point the point is i am talking about an
ideal of the university if i'm told that
pragmatism means i have to choose what
is facing me today
that is the abandonment of the notion of
an ideal and abstract ideal there is
such a thing as an abstract idea of the
western university we throw it out at
our peril and we do a disservice to
working class middle class ruling class
every class and what's worse is we
destroy education in the process please
don't do that i don't care what way you
vote this motion might be a bit of a
joke but what's that the heart of it is
deadly serious i don't care whether you
vote for me just agree with me thank you
[Applause]
just remember that universities have
been changing for hundreds of years and
they've always included a lot of
vocational work what's law what's
theology they were vocational studies
and engineering
some people may feel uneasy about
certain contemporary vacations i would
myself
the remedy surely is
to try to draw some lines to try to
distinguish things but not to say we
want to pull the drawbridge up and keep
you lot whoever they may be out
to keep out all but two percent probably
doesn't appeal to many people here
possibly not even declare to keep out
30 percent
well all but 30 percent seems to appeal
to quite a lot of people think about it
what would be the consequence of doing
that do you care more for the definition
of a word and which institutions are
called universities well perhaps you do
but if so i'm afraid
we gave that pass away probably in the
1960s
when there was the great expansion from
which many people in this room have
benefited
if we don't care about the word if we
care about the substance then it's about
making the quality of what goes on good
and if possible better and that's not
done by keeping people with aspirations
out
[Applause]
i was as i think is written on your song
sheet
director of the university
birth of dundee and
sinandrews and we had
a rector is
like a speaker
chairman
we had on one occasion a physics
graduate
who came to us the court of the
university
with a complaint
he had in his final physics examination
been given the question how would you
gauge the height of a skyscraper
using a barometer
and he had said
that he would attach a barometer to a
piece of string
take it to the top of the skyscraper
and lower it
when it reached the ground he would
measure the in-app string
and that would be the height of the
skyscraper
he was failed for showing a total
ignorance to physics
he complained to ask the court of the
university on the grounds that he had
been
asked a question given an essentially
correct answer
and received no marks which were
crucial to the quality of his degree
and we thought he had a point and
allowed him
to take that question again we appointed
an external examiner
and
when he arrived before this man he said
well you've got plenty of time to think
about it
what's your answer
he said it isn't as simple as that i
have been thinking about it
i could take the barometer to the top of
the skyscraper and drop it
and with an accurate stopwatch
time the descent
and bearing in mind that g equals 72
feet per second per second i could get a
pretty good idea or
this what you might have had in mind i
could take the barometric pressure
at the top of the building and then
again at the bottom
but on consideration what i would do
would be to go
to the caretaker
and say
[Music]
and say if you will tell me the height
of the skyscraper i will give you a
barometer
[Applause]
i have before me the result of your vote
you will recall that before the debate
people
were in favor
this number has slumped
to 453
those against have increased in fact
doubled
144 to 280
and three people still don't know
i'm sorry about that
thank you all very much for coming
you